what is the united nations going to do
and the answer is they can't do anything
in the ancient world
socrates of all people said that he was
not a citizen of athens alone he was a
citizen of the world our term
cosmopolitan comes from that concept
that he had
uh affinities with all the city-states
and indeed with all the people in the
world
in a very cynical fashion when alexander
the great in the latter fourth century
bc at the demise of the city-state went
into asia minor and then on to conquer
the persian empire he needed a
propaganda talking point and one of it
was he was going to usher in what he
called the brotherhood
of man a new ecumenical idea that
whether you were persian or greek you
were a human it sounds wonderful but the
idea was
that enlightened rulers from the
hellenic world would spread their
superior civilization all over the world
and it didn't last very well in roman
times romans being far more practical
they didn't talk about globalization as
much as reified it they made it concrete
but immediately there were voices within
rome that said the further a sovereign
nation expands
and globalizes the more difficult it is
to
maintain the solidarity of the people
the purity of the original founding
concepts the more we think we're making
people into romans the more they think
they are making us into other peoples
other than romans one of the problems
that globalists or cosmopolitans learned
very early in the 20th century during
the progressive movement
was
when you surrender sovereignty to these
international bodies
then who is the police
who polices the police
so the league of nations which was
envisioned under woodrow wilson's
versailles agenda
for a very brief time seemed to be
successful in adjudicating international
disputes of trade or jurisdiction or
borders until
adolf hitler
or the japanese militarist or joseph
stalin said i don't need to listen to
you
and so world war ii
doomed the first incarnation of a united
group of nations the league of nations
after world war ii the same suspicious
idea resurfaced with the united nations
but this time we were going to have a
security council
and they were going to be the world's
top powers the strongest the most
successful
and then they could be the enforcer but
the problem of course was that very
early on the soviet union was not
the solution to the problem but it was
the problem itself because there's
always going to be some country who's
powerful
by breaking the rules and going beyond
its own prerogative in other words an
anti-democratic china that has currently
a million and a half people in camps and
yet they're on the united nations
and they're a citizen of the world
and if the united nations
would decide that the chinese contrary
to the u.n charter
are putting people in concentration
camps
or they're harvesting organs from people
deemed not necessary
or they're forcing people to have
abortions that
don't fit their idea of family planning
or their bullying their neighbors
or they illegally created a base in the
spratly islands what is the united
nations going to do
and the answer is they can't do anything
in 2020 we saw an international pandemic
and our united nations charter medical
organization the world health
organization
warned us from the very beginning
do not issue a travel ban against china
and then we learned that the world
health organization was essentially
parroting or mimicking what china wanted
and why did they do that because of
chinese money and chinese pressure this
is not an aberration it's inherent in
the idea of global governance
that there's always going to be strong
powers who have agendas that are not
global in scope but they're national and
sovereign but if all the other countries
in the world surrender their sovereignty
and one powerful nation doesn't then
they have to come up with a mechanism of
collective defense
and so far in the history of man that's
never worked
you